oh
ah
all of this
an expression of infinity
everything you
me the ocean
the cities the planet all
of our thoughts feelings emotions
perceptions sensations
everything as an expression of infinity
how many different combinations
of infinity can you imagine
how many different expressions
can you imagine how many different
planets
can you imagine how many different
civilizations can you imagine
how many different bodies can you
imagine
vehicles can you imagine
how many different combinations of music
can you imagine
is it really that simple that we are the
eternal symphony
and that these are just songs
unique beautiful songs unique
vehicles for us to play in
how many different combinations of play
can you think of
how much child-like exploration can you
imagine
how many different combinations
of art painted on a canvas can you
imagine
that is this you are that i
and my father are one tatvam asi
you are that i am that we are that we
are the infinite we are the eternal
this is but one expression
welcome to this
unique painting that is what planet
earth is
that is what this civilization is that
is what this collective
dream is
ask yourself do i know myself as
infinity
do i know myself as eternity is that my
true nature
do i know myself as that once you know
yourself as the infinite once you know
yourself
as the eternal that is expressing itself
as your unique creative combination
of a human experiencing planet earth
then you know that is when you know
this is home
this is it this is infinity expressing
itself
this is a song that we are playing as a
symphony
this is a dreamed exploration that we
are immersed in
and it's beautiful every moment is peace
every moment is joy every moment is play
it's all art it's all so captivating
but are you aware enough of awareness
itself
to know your infinitude
and to know this as an expression of
that infinitive
every wave is a kiss from mother earth
every single wave is love
it's the ocean that reminds us on a wave
by wave basis just like your heart beats
and each one is love
love love
light light
infinity infinity
each wave is that
each heartbeat is that
the absolute infinite perfection
of exactly this expression
appearing as it is simply
this exactly as it is
is perfection
get yourself in awe
at the perfection that this is get
yourself in
awe at each and every single
stroke onto the canvas
because that is eternity expressing
itself that is infinity expressing
itself with each
and every single stroke
you are it we are
it expressing itself this is our true
nature going through all of the infinite
creative
modulations and combinations of
expressing ourselves
in these beautiful dreamed explorations
we are that
this is play this is infinity this is
child like creativity and expression
every moment is bliss every moment is
peace every moment is joy
if you relax back into your
infinitude you will recognize that
that is your true nature this is one
expression
of that
and then we ask ourselves how
to maximize our potential here how to
maximize
planetary prosperity and abundance
and harmony and maximizing the
well-being and actualization
of everybody's gifts redirect
attention on the nature of our infinite
awareness exploring these creation
designs
and how to maximize the next
people that come and portal in to be
able to
execute their unique gifts into the
world
because everybody deserves to contribute
their creative expression
we are in the beautiful venice
california
in los angeles
what are the architectures that maximize
planetary prosperity
ask yourselves that question two
questions i ask
two questions one what
is i simple as that the first question
what is i is that i
shared and is that i eternal
and is this but one expression of that
eternity
slash infinity and the second question
how to maximize
planetary prosperity two questions
what is i is that shared and eternal
and two how to maximize planetary
prosperity
those two questions will alone
absolutely bring you so much peace
so much joy so much prosperity so much
abundance just by asking yourselves
those two questions
and that's it those are the ultimate two
questions
what is that i is it shared is it
eternal is this but
one expression of infinity and that that
is our true nature
is these dreamed creation desires
the second question how to maximize
planetary prosperity
in this dreamed beautiful creation
design
those two questions will keep you
occupied for life
they're incredible they're fruitful
they bring wisdom they bring play they
bring creativity
and they bring the metaphysical truth
because everybody deserves to know the
metaphysical
truth of our true nature it's as simple
as that
metaphysical truth and maximizing
creativity
again what is i is that shared
is that eternal is this but one
expression of the infinite
and two how to maximize planetary
prosperity
that's it i adore you so much
i'm glad that we've been able to share
this beautiful sunset in venice together
it's been an absolute blast to be able
to
operate this channel called
simulation this channel called
simulation because ultimately these are
simulated
dreams ultimately we share these
simulated dreams
and we are that infinity expressing
itself through these
and i adore every single one of you i'm
super grateful that we have this
beautiful
channel and community
that's it those two questions that's it
what is i is that shared is that eternal
is this but one
expression of that infinitude
and two how to maximize planetary
prosperity
i adore you all thank you so much
i wish you all the absolute highest
flourishing and abundance such peace
love and light to you all
as well i'm so so grateful
you